this is the world's largest offshore
wind farm located in the Irish Sea it
covers the same area as 20,000 football
pitches and can power as many as five
hundred and ninety thousand homes the
European Parliament wants more of the
energy used across the EU to come from
renewable sources thirty-two percent by
2030 sukira more lograr la this carbon
is a co de nuestra colonia in alliance
or missing Quinta esta some posh
intermedia kilowatt arimathea from FLIR
companies generally deliver mundial in
largo film and emission is this water
treatment plant in eastern France is
creating its own energy with one of the
regional food specialities sauerkraut
the juice left over from sauerkraut
production is used to make biogas which
in turn runs the plant the EU wants to
make it easier for consumers to generate
store and use their own energy without
extra taxes or charges a lot of housing
needs to be more energy efficient I
think that is going to be a development
of course all the countries need to
implement it themselves but more energy
efficient houses is going to be the
biggest change for consumers under new
rules countries will have to prioritize
energy saving solutions and use those
savings to help poor or vulnerable
customers at least 14% of fuel used for
transport will have to come from
renewable sources and higher mission
biofuels like palm oil will be phased
out creating a cleaner greener Europe
you